hey guys time is almost up to win a
Nintendo switch and other amazing prizes
from yours truly so be sure to check the
link in the description below to throw
your name in the Hat for those fabulous
free gifts competition ends on the 29th
of this month so what are you waiting
for
have you ever been just playing a Zelda
game and then you stop and just go why
is the moon so weird and I'm not just
talking about the weird giant face from
the Moon and majora's mask though that's
probably more creepy and ominous than it
is weird i mean what's up with the Blood
Moon from breath of the wild the music
the lighting I mean the Zelda universe
is no stranger to well strange oddities
being present but the moon stands out as
one of the most bizarre elements of
Hyrule because at first glance the
rather normal-looking space rock doesn't
really seem like anything out of the
ordinary but when you think about the
mysterious activities that the moon is
directly linked to what if there's more
to this moon than meets the eyes
[Music]
in a video from fellow Zelda theorist
Nintendo black Crysis he breaks down the
science behind the blood moon event that
happens in breath of the wild basically
he compares the Blood Moon from breath
of the wild with a blood moon from the
real world which is only natural to
compare since the event is known to
occur IRL albeit pretty rarely to
summarize the video he concludes that
due to Princess Zelda stating that the
blood moon rises when Ganon's power is
at its peak and Ganon's power being
based out of darkness this would
scientifically explain that since the
land would grow with Ganon's darkness at
his powers peak red light would be the
only light left to be reflected off of
the moon's surface pretty meat right I
mean I was convinced until I started
thinking a little bit harder into the
subject probably too hard but that is my
job so anyway the first thing that stuck
out to me is that real life blood moons
also known as total lunar eclipses are
pretty rare like occurring up to once
every three years kind of rare
however blood moons and breath of the
wild are not that way I mean those
things can sometimes occur as often as
two nights in a row or more if we are to
assume that the planet Hyrule is on
let's call it planet H if we are to
assume that planet H operates at least
somewhat similarly to our own planet
Earth which I would assume it does given
it also has a similar Pope Sun moon day
and night cycle this would pose a
problem for the notion that breadth of
the wilds Blood Moon is purely
scientific in nature furthermore as NBC
stated a real-life Blood Moon occurs
when only red light is reaching the
moon's surface meaning the other 80% of
light isn't being reflected back at us
leaving to a much darker evening but in
breadth of the wild a blood moon doesn't
darken things up at all in fact the
world seems to brighten up with an eerie
red glow couple this with the clouds
suddenly and inexplicably changing their
speed and the repeated occurrences and
I'm convinced that breadth of the wilds
Blood Moon phenomenon isn't scientific
in nature at all it's magical oh yeah
and it also raises the dead which I'm
pretty sure is magical unless this is
actually the legend of zelda
Frankenstein's army or something like
but yeah the Blood Moon from breath of
the wild isn't the only time we've known
the moon to herald the rising of the
Dead rewind back in time to ocarina of
time I feel like I say that a lot in
this game when you're out and about
adventuring across hyrule field sooner
or later the sun will set and the moon
will rise and with it so do the dead as
soon as nightfall hits dozens of stall
children emerge from beneath the field
of Hyrule oh and by the way I did a
video with my buddy hyrule gamer last
Halloween regarding the strange
occurrence check it out if you want
links in the description below anyway
unless these undead beings just really
wanted to take a nice stroll under the
night sky and really didn't want a Sun
Tan the only thing that's changed from
the light of day is the light of the
Moon so okay why am i spending so much
time talking about the dead and the
light and the magical nature of the Moon
hold your horses I'm getting there
back in breath of the wild as many
people know Zelda has something specific
to say about the chilling night of the
Blood Moon she states that Ganon's power
rises to its peak under the Blood Moon
Ganon's power a magical Blood Moon
what's the correlation why should the
Moon react again and flexing on it a
little bit another clue we can ponder
from breath of the wild comes from the
final fight against calamity Ganon when
you're in combat beneath Hyrule Castle
with the Beast himself if it just so
happens to strike on the night of a
Blood Moon Ganon's health will be
refilled as if he had received no damage
at all as if he were rewound but
otherwise he has no way of healing
himself unless of course you're on hero
mode but that's besides the point
this begs the question if the Blood Moon
were truly under Ganon's control why
would he not use it to heal himself
every time you fight because if you
start the encounter and no Blood Moon
occurs he'll just receive damage and die
like normal implying he can't just
activate it whenever he wants even if
it's to save himself does this mean that
the Blood Moon happens outside of
Ganon's command what if it's not the
Moon reacting to Ganon's power but
rather Ganon's power reacting to the
moon but let's take a few steps back and
set something else up real quick we know
the moon is alive how from Majora's Mask
and yes I know that the world of termina
is most likely a parallel universe to
Hyrule which is to say it takes place
apart from the line
and universe that the usual games take
place in however due to its parallel
nature featuring the same yet different
characters and whatnot we can still
derive information from the world of
termina that can then be used to explain
certain aspects of the parallel
counterparts in mainland Hyrule in this
case the moon as creepy as it looks in
game it didn't always look like that if
you take a peek at the chair that the
mayor sits on you can see the moon's
original smiling face detailed on top
now yes this may even to some people be
more creepy than its current expression
but the point is that the moon changed
its expression but why would it do this
as its implied in-game I believe it
changed its expression when it was
subjugated by the power of Majora's Mask
and the Skull Kid and this is why it
appears angry or frustrated and even
cries yep you heard me it cries at least
twice in the form of precious gemstones
called the moon's tears I believe this
means the moon is being forced by majora
against its will to destroy the earth
I'm sorry to destroy termina contrasting
this with regular world high rules moon
no it may not have a face on it but it
does have something else in common it's
also being subjugated by a dark force
it's being used to resurrect or rewind
the dead but by Ganon instead of majora
so now let's tie this in with what we
were talking about before I got off on
my majora's mask comparison if we have a
magical living moon that is being used
by but operates independently of Ganon
the next logical question would be who
or what is the moon what's its
background is it a new entity entirely
or one that we've already seen in the
games well the first possibility I'd
like to bring up for the identity of the
Moon is the possibility that the moon is
either fully or in part a representation
of the goddess of time who is directly
mentioned in majora's mask the blood
moons theme seems to feature rewound
Tunes and the monsters and even Ganon
himself seemed to rewind back to life
and now this is kind of a bonus mini
theory that I'm just kind of gonna stick
in here but many people believe the
goddess of time is the Forgotten fourth
sister of the three golden goddesses who
created the world while I won't go too
far into this and you know the whole
theory of the tetra force and stuff like
that it could be that since didn't
create
the earth nehru created the law of the
world and for Rory created life the
fourth sister the goddess of time could
have created time and therefore the day
and night cycle represented by the Sun
but contrasted by the moon it seems like
the people of the land of termina
knowingly accept the existence of the
goddess of time and pairing that
knowledge with the fourth Triforce piece
represented on the Hylian Shield from
ocarina of time
definitely implies the validation of
this theory furthermore since the fourth
piece which in this case is representing
the goddess of time is both separated
from the other three pieces and also
inverted it could imply that the goddess
is against the other three which melds
well with the notion that the Blood Moon
aka the goddess of time assists ganon
and his Wiles another piece of evidence
that the goddess of time is a golden
goddess herself is the fact that she
also has a spiritual stone the moon's
tear could it be that the moon is either
being forced to or willingly is
partnered with Ganon and could this help
explain the strange backwards melody in
breath of the wild twos trailer is
Ganondorf being rewound back to life of
course if I follow this rabbit trail too
far I'll get into all sorts of stuff
like where's the wielder of the fourth
tetra force piece so I'll stop that
theory there and get back on track now
the next possibility is that the moon is
whatever demon or dark God resides in
the dark got a statue outside Hatano
village though I'd say I don't
personally believe this one due to the
nature and personality of the statues
resident I don't know I just can't see
it that guy's too funny but finally it
could always be a new unknown demon that
demise either created or cursed the moon
with way back in the days before ocarina
of time this would explain why the moon
seems to hold the power of Resurrection
over the dead even when it's set in a
universe without Ganon such as termina
implying the power over the undead was
given to the moon and not to Ganon but
of course this is all now in the realm
of speculation and on that note what do
you think let me know in a comment below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my crazy theory please be sure to
subscribe with that Bell icon if you
haven't already to stick around for all
the juicy Nintendo content right here at
mass antennae bandit and also like this
video if you enjoyed it to spread the
love as always humongous thank you to
all of my amazing patrons who make my
day
everyday if you're interested in getting
your name up here at the end of all of
my videos check out the links in the
description below for more info also
down there are the links to my social
media pages and hey don't forget about
the competition that's ending really
soon
that's all I've got for this video so I
hope you have a great rest of your day
this is Mastana Bandits signing out
peace
[Music]